mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir il a fait beau partout en france
pour ce premier dimanche de l'automne
voilà au moins un événement satisfaisant
et il n'a échappé à personne
voyons un peu ce que nous offre
l'actualité ce soir en suisse
échec du référendum sur l'interdiction
des exportations d'armes en grèce 30
touristes périssent dans l'incendié d'un
restaurant à rhodes en france c'est jean
claude andruet sur ferrari qui remporte
le tour auto
le tiercé il y a deux combinaisons
gagnantes ce soir je dis bien 2 3 13 et
10 et 13 3 et 10 à paris le mois dernier
le fils de l'ambassadeur de jordanie
avait été enlevé puis relâchés contre
une rançon de 200 mille francs et
personne n'en avait rien su cette
affaire avait été tenue secrète par ce
que l'on craignait qu'il s'agisse d'une
opération politique monté par des
fedayins il apparaît aujourd'hui qu'il
n'en est rien l'ambassadeur de jordanie
nous raconte ce qui s'est passé élevé
par deux personnes dans une voiture avec
des pistolets tu es là passer la nuit
là-bas chez eux jusqu'à m'a téléphoné
pour poser leurs conditions pour lui
après mon fils il ya eu de demande de
rançon elles ont demandé à rassurer
combien 200 mille francs nouveau nouveau
oui est-ce que ses ravisseurs vous ont
menacé vous même
non pas du tout ils ont simplement m'a
dit si je vois rebond qui suit va encore
une fois je dois suivre leur leur
condition et ressortent la remise de
rançon comment s'est-elle déroulée
eh bien on précisé
mais 10 et de 38 route pour aller payer
aviez-vous presse darroussin qui
quelqu'un va passer pour me dire un mot
et jeunesse prend 2,6 kg
j'apporte dans ma main vous êtes allez
vous même donc je suis et les mets
moi-même oui il y avait un mot de passe
elio un mot de passe était chateaubriand
votre fiche est de rétine
mon fils est étudiant il est juste
terminer son baccalauréat elle a 17 ans
est ce qu'il a été menacé de mort
lui-même
non pas du tout elle était allée vers
elle était n'était pas maltraités du
tour pas de violence pas de même pas
juste de force violence tout
qui sont les auteurs de cet enlèvement
votre avis je crois c'est un bandit
professionnel ce quel poids on prétend
que septembre noir ne serait pas
étranger à cette opération qu'en pensez
vous ce n'est pas de façon deux actions
du septembre noir ça ne va pas du tout
septembre loire ne demande pas de rançon
mon premier sens et
la façon de cette opération la façon
dans lesquelles le monsieur jamais sur
le mât téléphone et m'a parlé
sept garçons professionnel c'est un
certain nombre de métiers ce n'est pas
allant de septembre noir mais des
fidèles
je ne crois pas désormais êtes vous
protégez moi je suis bien protégé oui
est ce que vous avez demandé un renfort
dans votre protection non pas du tout je
suis bien protégés et ma famille aussi
de l'ambassade aussi je suis bien
protégés je n'ai pas besoin de demander
la politique maintenant de référendum
aujourd'hui en europe
les norvégiens se prononce depuis cet
après midi sur l'adhésion de leur pays
au marché commun en suisse la population
devait dire si elle voulait tout non
interdire les exportations d'armes que
certains jugée immorale
les suisses ont répondu non de justesse
leurs exportateurs continueront donc de
présenter des mitrailleuses
à côté des montres et du chocolat
à l'origine du référendum un scandale
qui avait éclaté en 1960 l'opinion
publique avait alors découvert avec
stupeur que les nigérians utiliser des
canons de fabrication suisse pour
abattre les avions de la croix rouge qui
transportait des ce fourbi offre une
enquête avait ensuite permis d'établir
qu'une firme suisse toujours fournissez
des armes à plusieurs pays soumis à
l'embargo des pays en état de guerre
tels que l'egypte et israël
ce commerce se réaliser en marge des
règlements existants avaient révolté
certaine conscience qui s'étaient
regroupés au sein du mouvement contre
les exportations d'armes en recueillant
cinquante mille signatures
ce mouvement devait provoquer
l'organisation du référendum
d'aujourd'hui
le peuple suisse s'est donc prononcée il
a rejeté l'interdiction d'exporter des
armes
il a refusé de suivre ceux qui pensent
que ce commerce est incompatible avec la
neutralité de la confédération les
suisses ont préféré adopter la position
de leurs gouvernements qui tout en étant
partisan d'une plus grande
réglementation dans ce domaine et contre
une interdiction pure et simple de ses
exportations
autre argument qu'a joué auprès des
électeurs les autorités fédérales
avaient déclaré que la suppression des
ventes d'armes aurait pour conséquence
une augmentation du chômage
et puis en allant voter le suisse moyen
du tout de même penser à ses 325
millions de francs français que rapporte
ses exportations d'armes
et n'oublions pas que chez les suisses
le sentiment de neutralité n'en pas n'en
perd pas le sens des affaires
autre nouvelle de l'étranger le calme
règne aux philippines après la
proclamation de la loi martiale on ne
sait toujours rien du complot d'extrême
gauche dont le président marcos a fait
état pour prendre tous les pouvoirs à
washington demain réunion du fonds
monétaire international deux questions
importantes à l'ordre du jour la réforme
du système monétaire international et la
réélection du président monsieur pierre
paul schweitzer un français qui occupe
ce poste il se heurte à l'opposition des
états unis
il nous a confié ses intentions avant la
réunion de demain
vous savez comme mon mandat expire le
1er
septembre 1973 alors forcément un
certain nombre d'administrateurs se sont
posé la question de savoir ce qui se
passerait après j'ai personnellement
indiqué que je serai prêt à continuer à
servir jusqu'à l'âge de 65 ans il
c'était le voeu manifeste du conseil
d'administration
ce n'est plus un secret que le
gouvernement américain a pris une
position négative en ce qui concerne le
renouvellement de mon mandat je n'ai ni
démissionné ni menacé de démissionner je
suis si je puis dire de plus humble
serviteur de nos pays membres tels
qu'ils sont représentés au conseil
d'administration
et c'est au conseil d'administration
seul il appartient de prendre une
décision
nouvelles de france maintenant mes gars
forts ministre d'état chargé des
affaires sociales a constitué neuf
groupes de travail qui avec la
collaboration des organisations
syndicales et professionnelles et sous
la direction du secrétaire d'état
christian poncelet doivent permettre la
mise en oeuvre rapide des réformes
sociales réunion ce week-end de la
direction politique nationale du ps eut
on ya parlé notamment des prochaines
élections
monsieur rocard nous parle du prêt
principal d'un programme élaboré dans
l'unité retrouvée
quel regard on peut dire d'ores et déjà
que l'un des thèmes de la campagne pour
le psu ce sera notre gestion et le plan
il ya là une apparente contradiction
entre ces deux notions qui l'une
implique la liberté et l'autre une
certaine rigueur
en effet c'est toute la difficulté notre
manifeste
l'ordre du jour ne nous répond baisse et
se manifeste
vers quelle société c'est le résumé
notre projet socialiste
nous sommes des militants socialistes
mais nous sommes des militants
socialistes qui voulons construire une
société libre l'expérience soviétique
nous paraît suffisamment grave pour
insister là dessus
qui dit société livre dit société dans
laquelle le pouvoir est équilibrée par
les responsabilités qui sont prises à la
base et c'est ça que veut dire
l'autogestion elle veut dire des
entreprises gérées en assemblée sur
délégation par leurs travailleurs
elle veut dire des communes des
quartiers administré par leurs habitants
directement
même s'il ya des procédures de
délégation cet accent sur la liberté
nous l'avons beaucoup poussé et tout le
travail de ces deux jours était
d'examiner le contenu même de cette
autogestion de la définir avec autant de
précision qu'il est possible
c'est un des chapitres de notre
manifeste mais en effet ça ne va pas de
soi et il est vrai que si chacun fait
par petits groupes ce qu'il veut dans
son coin la société sera le plus grand
chaos la plus grande pagaille
l'expérience de nos amis yougoslave qui
sont une société en autogestion montre
bien qu'il ya des difficultés
les difficultés nos amis yougoslave elle
s'explique parce que leur plan est
insuffisant
si bien que ça a été pour nous aussi un
problème de voir comment faire une
planification une véritable orientation
du destin national des choix politiques
et économiques sans trop sans pour
autant violer la liberté des
organisations qui seront les vieilles
les communes et aussi les entreprises
gérées par leurs travailleurs il y faut
de la souplesse il faut des mécanismes
adaptés il faut prendre savoir prendre
des décisions globales que on
décentralise qu'on détail au niveau d'en
dessous
et c'est tout le détail du projet de
manifeste que nous soumettons la
délibération des militants du parti
socialiste unifié
voilà pour la politique des nouvelles de
la presse maintenant vous retrouverez
demain chez votre marchand de journaux
un nouvel hebdomadaire d'information il
s'appelle le poids il est lancé par les
dissidents de l'express il coûte 3
francs 50 et se présente dans le format
classique sur un très beau papier genre
tu fais rédacteur en chef adjoint du
quoi répond maintenant aux questions que
lui a posée à la ferme back sur ce
nouvel hebdomadaire
j'en suis fait pourquoi le point bas le
besoin de les jouer mon rôle à bord
voilà la leçon numéro 1 sa couverture
pourquoi parce qu'il ya un an et un
certain nombre de journalistes des
professionnels qui se sont dit qu'il y
avait peut être la place en france qui
avaient probablement la faute de place
en france pour un journal qui sait le
dire la vérité
c'est une tentative à la fois simple et
audacieuse et on va voir si on a raison
ou tort on dit lis actuellement une
crise de la presse
alors est ce facile de faire un nouveau
journal et comment peut-on trouver
l'argent
c'est pas très commode mais les choses
se sont déroulées comme ça on dit
on a d'abord eu l'idée à quelques-uns de
ce journal on y arrive et on l'a
dessinée on l'a calculé et on l'a
proposé ensuite un certain nombre de
gens qui avaient de l'argent en leur
disant est ce que voulait le prendre clé
en main et avec le contrat qu'on vous
propose un certain nombre ont dit
peut-être d'autres ont dit non et
finalement hachette a dit oui et voilà
on dit que votre journal et avant qu'il
sorte ça ne sort que demain et d'un
journal gouvernemental alors c'est une
réponse simple que vous demandez les
hommes politiques ont des ambitions
politiques
les journalistes ont des ambitions de
journalistes la confusion des genres
c'est mortel qu'est ce que nous voulons
dire en tant que nous ne serons pas un
journal ni gouvernementale ni anti
gouvernementales c'est que ce problème
nous paraît très secondaire bien sûr en
france est pas encore quelque chose
d'admis aux etats unis c'est un truc
ennemis les grands magazines
d'information sont parfois pour le
gouvernement s'y trouvent que le
gouvernement des bruits molle et parfois
contre bien nous nous allons être comme
ça et nous allons donc probablement un
peu surprendre ceux qui s'imaginaient
que nous allions être systématiquement
pour eux comme ceux qui s'imaginent et
le contraire quels sont les grands
titres des numéros 1 bat bien sûr c'est
l'événement comme ball qui fait les
titres des titres c'est ce qui vient de
se passer est depuis quinze jours en
france
cette espèce de crise qui pour nous
n'est pas du tout une crise aranda si je
puis dire c'est une crise du régime
français avec toutes ses composantes
mais il ya beaucoup d'autres choses il
ya des services nous allons nous occuper
beaucoup de rendre service aux gens et
nous allons nous occuper beaucoup de
consommation il y aura les bancs
d'essais sur des produits
il ya une partie culturelle qui est
assez convenable
il y aura tout ce qu'on trouve dans un
journal en essayant de serre au plus
près les événements rappelant que le
poids voit son titre contesté par le
groupe des journaux d'extrême gauche
politique hebdomadaire qui estime être
propriétaire de l'appellation le poids
et qui éditera dans la semaine un
magazine d'extrême gauche portant ce
titre le nouvel observateur notre
hebdomadaire publie dans son numéro de
demain un sondage intéressant sur les
jeunes et le droit de vote
j'en ai retenu deux résultats aux
élections 57 % seulement des jeunes
ces résultats concernent pardon les
élections 57 % seulement des jeunes de
18 à 20 ans veulent avoir le droit de
vote et aux élections 20% se
prononcerait pour un candidat de la
gauche et 19% pour un candidat de la
majorité gouvernementale d'information
générale de grèce
a-rod hier soir le meilleur restaurant
de l'île était plein de touristes
subitement les murs fait de planches et
de roseaux s'enflamme il y a qu un tout
petit escalier pour sortir trente et une
personnes périssent brûlées vives
il y à 16 blessés dans plusieurs
personnes qui ont sauté par les fenêtres
en france fait-divers émouvant un chien
retourne mourir à l'endroit où sa
maîtresse a péri dans un accident il ya
quelques jours près de bordeaux une
automobiliste parisienne est tuée dans
un accident de la route
son chien affolée mais un dance enfuis
dans la forêt proche
à l'arrivée des sauveteurs
mais le lendemain des témoins devaient
découvrir le corps de l'animal à
l'endroit même où sa maîtresse était
mort il avait été écrasé s'est il fait
tuer volontairement at il voulu suivre
sa maîtresse dans la mort c'est un
vétérinaire qui connaît bien autour de
la norma n 1 qui retrouve un endroit
ceci c'est très compréhensible ça fait
appel à au sens de l'orientation du
chien tout d'abord qui est une chose
assez mal connu mais enfin qui est très
puissant puisqu'on sait que des chiens
ont fait pas plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres des fois pour retrouver leurs
maîtres et puis également à des choses
plus simples on sait qu'un chien prend
des points de repère l'oeuf active des
ponts de repères visuels et des points
de repère auditifs et arrive très bien à
retrouver un endroit dont il est parti
selon vous il a donc l'illusion de
retrouver 100 m en revenant sur cet
endroit
oui alors là c'est là que je crois il
fut il faille faire un petit point de
récapitulation sur ce qu'est le
psychisme du chien parce qu'on a fait on
a assimilé comportement du chien au
comportement de l'homme ça conduit à de
belles histoires mais c'est totalement
faux un chien se donne un mètre où on
lui donne un maître et se mettre va
petit à petit remplacer ce qu'était le
chef de meute
chez les chiens sauvages il va se mettre
devenir le pilier l'univers
psychologique du chien bien en ce moment
là le chien dès qu'il aura un sentiment
d'angoissé ou la sécurité va revenir
vers ce m instinctivement il va il y
aura besoin de cette protection il n'en
connais pas d'autre
est ce vous explique ça va beaucoup plus
loin un chien ne peut pas à projeter
quelque chose dans le futur ou même dans
l'abstrait il ne connaît pas ça
proprement il n'a pas notion et il ne
connaît pas la mort des autres pour lui
un chèque à temps sur la tombe de son
maître par exemple il attend que le
maître reviennent et lui donne à manger
il lui procure son affection mais il n'a
pas idée que le maître ne puisse pas
revenir et ceci est tellement vrai que
si vous enlevez un animal qui est pris
de telles manifestations et que vous
leur plongée dans un foyer dans un
milieu quelconque
eh bien il va automatiquement se
remettre à manger il retrouvera toute
attente être sur la tombe de son maître
mais c'est tout
attendre que les chiens parle pour avoir
le fin mot sur cette question les
rabbins du pari tiercé viennent de me
parvenir voici alors l'ordre d'arrivée
conforme et et 3 13 10 ou 13 3 10 les
rapports 629 190 pour 1 franc dans
l'ordre naturellement ordre différent
310 francs pour 1 franc le salon de
l'auto maintenant le salon de l'auto va
s'ouvrir prochainement
en octobre on vous le savez nous
poursuivons les essais de nos modèles ce
soir une voiture hollandaise entièrement
automatique le coupé daf 66 c'est une
six chevaux qui existent également en
break et en berline commercialisable dès
le mois d'octobre elle sera vendue selon
la version choisie entre 12350 et 15
1600 francs après s'être tour à tour
prénommé 44 puis 33 et enfin daf 55
voici maintenant la petite dernière
hollandaise la daf 66 à vrai dire cette
66 et une dame 55 plus élaboré elle doit
du reste de la remplacer dans un avenir
très proche
si surtout sur l'esthétique de la
voiture que les stylistes hollandais ont
fait porter leur effort et lignes sont
maintenant plus moderne la partie avant
été entièrement redessiné désormais la
calandre rectangulaire encadre les
phares et les clignotants se retrouvent
sous le nouveau pare choc
le moteur quant à lui n'a pas changé
c'est toujours un renault 11 centimètres
cubes qui autorise une vitesse de pointe
et de croisière de près de 135
kilomètres heure il manque de puissance
et de nervosité ce qui rend les
dépassements très souvent problématique
en revanche le vario matic ce système
d'entraînement continue par de courroie
qui est unique au monde à gagner en
souplesse et la tenue de route en
qualité malgré tout la daf semble
manquer de stabilité au freinage est
très sensible au vent latéral
la suspension reste ferme et
l'habitabilité en dehors des places
avant et discutent à pour les passagers
de grande taille
l'équipement est sobre mais complet un
bon point aussi pour la finition
extrêmement soignée pour une petite
voiture un standing moyen prochaines
informations à 23h38 précisent elles
sont représentées par ladislas de hoyos
vous remercie de votre attention et où
seuls de passer une excellente soirée au
revoir